resistió mejor cuba aunque la variante
omicron expertos nacionales e
internacionales opinan que si el linaje
del virus detectado en diciembre no
afectó tanto a la isla como a otros
países y ejerció menos presión sobre su
sistema hospitalario en la mayoría de
los países el pico con negras operó los
picos pandémicos anteriores sin embargo
el pico de nosotros se ha quedado muy
por debajo de los picos pandémico
anteriores lo que demuestra también que
nuestra vacuna irá a ver inmunizado a la
población ha sido efectivo en la isla
los científicos se felicitan por las
compañías de vacunación del país más del
88% de la población recibió la pauta
completa ha sido muy importante
indiscutiblemente las vacunas de un
valor gigantesco pero también la
estrategia que se siguió en nuestro país
para aplicar esas vacunas que no es lo
que ha pasado en algunos países que no
lo han hecho de una forma uniforme de
una forma intensiva otro punto a
destacar cuba fue el primer país del
mundo a empezar la vacunación masiva de
niños a partir de dos años mientras
muchas vacunas como facer o modernas
todavía no han sido aprobadas para los
menores de cinco años no nos
imaginábamos que íbamos a ser el único
país del mundo que iba a enfrentar la
ola de omicron con toda su población
pediátrica vacunada y que íbamos a poder
ver realmente el impacto que tenía la
vacunación pediátrica en el tamaño de la
incidencia de toda la enfermedad y eso
yo pienso que era una demostración muy
importante de en qué medida vacunar a la
población pediátrica no es solamente un
problema de proteger a los niños es
también un problema de proteger a la
sociedad de manera general cuba
desarrolló sus propias vacunas a pesar
del bloqueo económico de eeuu estas ya
se usan en venezuela nicaragua vietnam y
grant y la habana solicitará en las
próximas semanas la aprobación de dos de
ellas por la ms para que puedan
comercializarse a nivel internacional